Welcome to Blind Spot.
Actually, let's make that PUBG Blind Spot.
It's a 5v5 PvP game from a top-down view.
But watch your step.
Into the darkness lies the blind spot.
You can't see them, but they can see you.
Danger is literally around every spot.
Plant the bomb, defend the site, Haven't I played this a
million times before?
Well, hold that thought, because this is where we change the
rules.
Pick a route and let's break in.
Wait, hold up.
Keep it down.
Use your elbow.
Slip in quietly.
Watch every blind spot.
Shields up the front.
Use everything you've got.
Maybe Red Ship Amplifier this time.
Then, stealth mode.
Ambush.
Or, flashbang.
Breaching hook, blue chip detector.
Ambush.
Wait.
What if they're waiting to ambush us?
As long as we've got your back, you'll clear that path
eventually.
Alright, here we are at the crypt site.
Man, look at that defense.
Let's bust these barricades open.
It's your showtime.
Smash it.
Blow it up!
Destroy everything!
Time to plant the decryptor.
But heads up, this is their last stand.
And they won't go down either.
Pop smoke and blind the defense.
Still too many hostiles?
Screw it!
Just force your way in and tank it with the shield!
Now, planting is the ideal way to win, sure.
But the decryptor's down there, and you're the last one
standing, then lock in.
It's time to make a highlight reel.
Double kill, triple kill, quadr kill, clutch.
Every angle counts.
PUBG Blindspot.
Oh, before I begin, I will have to mention a huge shout out
and thank you to PUBG Blindspot.
for today's sponsor yes they sponsored this entire
tournament so huge thank you to them if you guys want to
support this stream this tournament and pubg blind spot
please feel free to click on the link pinned in the chat and
either twitch or youtube um and or in the description on
youtube it really does help out a lot wow i have to make the
disclaimer first so that you guys know we are sponsored here
so what brings me here today a very rare multi-stream day
we're both and Yumi are back together again, and I hope you
two will play nice.
All right, you two up there on the top right, I see you two
up there.
You guys better treat each other well.
You two are brothers.
Better treat each other well, guys.
Yeah, ambush.
The donkey bird ambush.
All right, so the reason why we are doing a multi-stream is
because the tournament's up on February 15th and 16th.
Today's not the tournament, by the way.
Just a little disclaimer, a little reminder, guys, today is
not the tournament.
It's actually next week on February 15th to 16th.
Today is just the announcement of the tournament.
So I'm going to give you guys the details, what the
tournament structure is going to be like.
Who's going to be playing here, playing in my tournament?
There will be four teams.
You guys all see the, saw the captains, they got announced
already earlier this week.
But we'll finally know who are their teammates today.
But yes, like I said, the tournament itself will be a
multi-stream as well.
So for those who are at Twitch, you guys, Timmy, the Timmy's
over there, they will get the full casting and broadcast of
the tournament itself.
So the multiple team POVs, the match POVs, the casting, the
interviews, that's what the Timmy's are going to get.
The Yimmys over here on YouTube, you guys are going to get
the individual POV.
um of my channel so of like my pov of like how my gameplay
is going to be like um and you know my pov of the entire
tournament itself so that's what youtube's going to get and
that's what twitch is going to get so you guys will have to
watch both streams to get both sides of whatever is going on
i almost swore there but i have to remember i am sponsored
today i was like whatever the is going on anyway like I said
my twitch shadow will have the full casting production side
of the entire tournament while on YouTube I will have my POV
with my team and that is why we're gonna be multi streaming
today so you guys can already you know get used to like the
pattern of watching both streams at the same time you know
get you getting used to it anyway now before we begin we're
going to watch another video you guys might have already
seen this video before but it is the video announcement of
my tournament that is sponsored by pubg blind spot again
huge shout out to them thank you again for uh for reaching
out to me they're like we want to sponsor you to organize
the very first n a tournament uh for this game and i was
very scared because i haven't organized or hosted a
tournament in a long time because i've been very very busy
and at first I was like, are you sure I could just be a
participant?
And you're like, no, we want to have your name, your brand
on this tournament.
And we want you to be the very first, um, the very first,
uh, host for our game for this tournament.
So, so here we go.
Here we go.
Um, so yeah, like I said, this is, uh, fully sponsored by
them.
Um, and, uh, and I cannot wait for next week.
It's, it's gonna, oh my gosh, I cannot wait.
production side is they made all of these graphics you see
this cool animated graphic behind me a little animated
background they've made that almost all the oh okay not all
not almost all the asses i did they provided me with all the
asses i just have to be here that's the best part as
compared to like the other times i've hosted tournaments uh
where i have to like manage everything i just have to show
up yay So they made all these amazing assets for me to use
for the announcement stream.
So huge shout out to the production side of PUBG Blindspot.
We love free stuff, don't we?
Anyway, let's watch another trailer.
You guys might have already seen this trailer before, but
this was the announcement trailer on my tournament.
It does provide some of the details, which I will go in
depth later on.
But here we go.
2025 is over.
And so is the way.
Let the real games begin.
We don't have much time, so lock in.
Blindspot launches into early access.
A new era begins together with Doki Bird.
Hey, that's me!
This isn't just an update.
Strategy, mind games, and entire new formula to win.
You're about to witness the evolution of gameplay.
Who will be the first to show us these grand changes?
These are the players that I have my eyes on.
and are ready to bring the fun.
Some of them might take big risks, so we'll just play for
Chaos, and others might be the surprise star.
Don't you want to know?
Let them show us.
This match is going to carry my name.
It's no small game.
That's right, a total of 15,000 USD, and the winner takes
$7,000.
Oh my God, that's a lot of money.
Get out yourself to see who takes the spotlight.
Working Cash T action?
Get your notes ready because we got it all right on screen.
Gotta write that down right now.
This match will be broadcast on my channel, Doki Bird.
You don't want to miss it out.
There won't be a second to miss, so tune in and see what
type of crazy plays your favorite creator is going to bring
out.
The plan for victory is ready in motion.
Well, I guess we better tune in and follow closely.
It's your turn to experience the blind spot.
Where's the new era on my stage?
I'll be waiting, but don't be late.
Whoa!
That's right!
A blind spot!
Oh, it is free to play, by the way.
So you can actually get joined right now in the early
access.
It's free to play and we love free stuff.
Just feel free to click on the link.
in my two chats on twitch and youtube or in the description
below on the youtube and you can check out the game yourself
guys um okay funny funny story originally uh the trailer uh
was not narrated by me um but when we were going over it we
were like oh it feels a little you know we want to add more
like you know because it is a dokeyberg tournament and they
were like how about you narrate this instead of like you
know the voiceover because at first i was like whoa the the
guy voicing You know, he needs more personality in there,
more oomph to it.
And they're like, how about you narrate this?
And then I accidentally did not see the message for two
days.
And the deadline was, like, in two days.
And I was like, oh my God, I'm so sorry.
I'm so out of it.
And I was like, I did it.
I was like, don't worry, I got you.
Bam, there you go.
Thank you, pre-recorded, Doki.
I really appreciate it.
Another funny story, but the tournament was actually
originally was supposed to be on Valentine's Day, too.
It was originally supposed to be on February 14th, but I was
like, no, that's my dog's birthday.
So I really appreciate them letting me adjust the tournament
dates because I was like, I'm sorry.
That's my dog's birthday.
I gotta celebrate my dog's birthday on the 14th.
So, like, oh, that's okay.
We can have it the day after it's that.
Okay, I was like, yeah, that's a lot better.
That's the day after my dog's birthday.
I was like, I'm sorry, it's true dish.
So, I really appreciate them being super flexible on the
dates itself.
So, yeah, like, they've been very accommodating, very
flexible.
I really appreciate it.
lady but for the time hey we all we all love dad here okay
it's his birthday it's his special day um anyone uh uh let
us pull up the slides you guys are itching in anticipation
who is gonna be in this tournament uh all right let me all
right goodbye big dokey hello smaller dokey whoa look at
that mean they made the logo too isn't the logo so pretty
donkey bird creator match pubg blind spot look that's me i
like how they color coded too to my colors as well all right
so for those who are wondering what is pubg blind spot um it
is um here's a little fun fact it's actually developed by a
very small team uh fewer than 20 developers uh who made this
game and um it's not battlegrounds In fact, it is its own
little thing.
So you guys might have remembered me playing this before in
a previous sponsor as well.
So the best part of this game is that it's free to play.
So you can actually try to gain yourself right now in early
access.
And it's basically like a top-down 5v5 tactical shooter.
So you know the drill regarding tactical shooters.
So you have a defense and attack side round.
And your goal is to either prevent the team from planting
the bomb or be the one to plant the bomb.
So, you know, you remember when during the last time I
played this game in the other, the earlier early axis, like
the guy that we were against, he was like against the wall.
And I was like, I'm going to breach that wall.
And I just, I just like, I destroyed the wall.
And he was just right there.
I was like, shoot him.
So, so I hope we get a lot.
I'm definitely going to be breaching a lot of walls next
week.
I'll be like, guys, don't worry.
He's definitely going to be on that other side.
I'm going to breach that wall.
Anyway, so yeah, you can destroy walls, wallbang, as you
guys saw in the trailer.
Shoot someone with a grenade launcher, which obviously
won't.
I'm going to try that one time.
And it's definitely not going to back.
I feel like when you guys see my team, you're going to know
like one of us is going to try that.
not gonna go wrong definitely nothing's gonna go badly from
that and we can use all types of util for an advantage um
and a lot of the utility is mapped to specific agents so
like each agent has its own utility its own um its own
specific guns and everything so you have to find which
perfect which agent is perfect for your playstyle uh but
yeah also another great thing is that their shared vision
combat.
So what that means is that your team shares enemy sightings
and lines of sight in real time.
So whether your teammate sees, you can see as well.
So basically your teammate can give you wall hacks as long
as they aren't incompetent and die.
Just don't die.
That's all we ask.
So we can always have wall hacks as long as they don't die.
oh i see also don't worry if you are not like very into like
the whole 5v5 tactical part of the gameplay there is team
death match um if you want to check out the game yourself
like i said there is team death match for those who just
don't want to go just want to go ungabunga uh but uh but in
the tournament we are going to be playing the um the other
game mode which is the search and destroy so the attack and
defense side uh so yeah anyway next slide which i control so
i'm telling myself next slide uh nsd welcome thank you for
the five gift and chips thank you thank you all right so
there are some patch notes that uh so i have to let you guys
know for those who have played the earlier access and have
seen the previous stream i've done for the sponsor stream um
they have changed some things um in this game compared to
the last time we looked into it so anyway small dokey will
be a smaller dokey now all right so anyway so um the first
thing that they added that we didn't see before is they
added this thing called down but not out um so in the
previous sponsor we didn't see this game um this ability
before so um basically I know this is gonna be super uh
funny when we do this in the tournament uh I know like a lot
of things are gonna go wrong when this happens in the
tournament But basically, what this means is that when you
kill someone, they don't full dive.
So they're down.
So you need to double tap them to kill someone.
So there is a revive system, which they added in the early
axis.
So they enter a down state.
And I can already imagine one of my teammates.
who you will find out later on who it is it's gonna be
shouting res me he's gonna be shouting res me come on res me
i'm safe it's not me okay it's not me okay technically it's
my entire team my entire team is is that player
safe guys i swear to god and the okay but another plus side
of this new update is that um they also can they can crawl
so so if you don't fully kill someone um they can crawl up i
can imagine you knock someone they just crawl away like
where do they go um but they can crawl away and they do
share vision um they can also share vision even though if
even if they're crawling um um so the shame crawl to me i
just want to do this okay if i have a chance in the
tournament i definitely i'm gonna knock someone down and
just watch them crawl away i'll be like all right boy lead
me to the rest of your teammates i know you want to oh
you're gonna lead me to someone that's gonna revive you lead
me to them
yeah I I can see some people doing that next week another
thing that they have changed I believe yeah they have
adjusted in before they wall bang you he takes you to one of
the walls and you get shot that's that at that point that's
just karma as I played with my food for too long um other
things they have added a mini map um shooting mechanisms
have improved um they have changed some of the stuff on the
maps so like if you notice some things from the early
earlier access like the ones before uh they have changed a
few of these things and yeah and also expanded decrypt your
placement range um i believe has been yeah they have like a
placement range to it now anyway so these are patch note
number one patch note number two that they wanted me to let
you guys know is that they have added a new character yay so
there's a new new agent here his name is blaze a new
operator uh he uses he has a molotov gadget and also uses
the the ump 45 the ump 45 so this is the new operator that
they added uh for the newest early axis um and then there's
like a bunch of adjustments to a bunch of the other
characters like um buddy zen patch and haze so if you guys
have played this game before um these characters have been
adjusted for the newer the current early axis so they are a
little bit different so zen for example he is only attack
only you could have played him in defense and attack Now
he's attack only.
Patch, he changed from defense only to attack defense.
So you can play her in both attack defense.
And he changed some stuff regarding Hayes' kit in general.
So you can't.
What the?
Okay, I didn't even realize this.
But in the past, he had a weapon that had headshot one hit
kill.
They thankfully removed that.
Thank God.
That, you know what?
No, that does seem a little bit...
broken so that's gone now don't worry that is gone now he
does not one shot headshot kill now so luckily we're safe um
so did it balance that out and yeah they change buddies uh
gadget as well so now he has what a camera drone toy
penetration gadget so that used to be haze's oh my god hey
oh yeah i remember haze had the penetration oh yeah haze was
crazy broken i remember now so yeah of that anymore uh thank
god uh all right those are all the new changes for the
current um for the cornfield of the early access so you were
used if you did play this before if all of these things
changed as well and we got a new new operator blaze all
right next up team captains yes so team captains this
tournament has um It has VTubers and Fleshy's, so it's a mix
of both.
And two team captains, as it was announced earlier, is me.
That's me.
Tokei Bear, Lily Pichu, Muda, and Sub-Rose.
I- Rosa, sorry.
Sub-Rosa.
I apologize if I mispronounce your names.
I, English is my very first language, but unfortunately, I
am a little bit illiterate.
I am very sorry.
these are the team captains um it is a team of five for each
team so they each pick we each picked our own teammates for
this tournament uh all right next up prizes the prize money
tournament structure so as i said before um this is a 15 000
tournament and it is fully funded fully sponsored by pubg
blind spot again thank you again yay thank you for funding
entire tournament and also helping me with the assets um and
uh they also are helping with the casting and the production
so um the production side of the the tournament stream is
going to be a very uh what's the word very high quality
because they actually got like a cat like they got she got
real casters instead of like you know uh me and mint trying
to trying to cast this so they they got actual professional
casters for this tournament and also a professional
production team uh for like the camera shots and everything
and the swapping between scenes so I won't be controlling
the uh I won't be solo controlling the entire tournament
stream this time like I have in the previous uh things I've
organized so there's going to be an actual professional
production team that's handling all of that so huge shout
out to PUBG blindspot for taking care of all this for me um
anyway so first place first place is 7,000 dollars.
Second place is $3,000 and third place is $2,000.
So everybody, everybody wins except for last place, but
everybody,
everyone gets money except for last, everyone gets money.
Um, anyway, other than that, we do also have a special
prize.
It's just, just don't get last, but everyone gets money,
guys.
um anyway so there are special everyone wins um not actually
the fine print um and yeah the fine print anyway so so there
are also uh special prizes so each individual uh whoever the
individual who gets
the most valued player in the entire tournament gets an
additional $2,000.
And the kill leader can also get $1,000.
So we do have these two as the special incentives for those
who want to, you know, be like extra sweaty.
So an individual can potentially even get both 2,000 or
1,000 at the same time.
If they're both the kill leader and MVP.
so technically last place could technically get kill leader
guys they could technically do it um and i believe wait let
me message um let me message just to be sure because i
wasn't fully sure about this one detail about how mvp is
selected so let me shoot this message real quick just to be
sure because I remember we were talking about this before um
so um so I just want to fully confirm before I say it
because that'll be a little awkward if I said it and then
the organizers you're like um that's uh that's not how we're
doing it so um regarding how MVP is selected anyway so other
than that this is the schedule uh February 6th right now uh
at 3 p.m PST which i just started uh the announcement stream
of all the tournament of the tournament itself february 15th
and 16th like i said this is it starts at the exact same
time um as this announcement stream um but group stage uh
will be at 3 p.m psc uh for day one and grand finals will
also be um will also be at 3 p.m um psc um uh so just
letting you guys know it we to keep it very easy to remember
um every day of this tournament is at 3 p.m pst so we're not
like you know jump scaring everyone on how uh on how it's
done um okay so so so i'm just confirming how mvp is
selected for this right now um but yeah so uh group stage is
most likely it okay most not most likely it is i am the i
don't know why i said most likely when i am in the
tournament but it is uh uh group stage uh round robin-esque
um and then the grand final is where like the elimination
actually starts all right next slide there we go i knew it
the overview there we go so format uh i oh all right so mvp
this is how mvp is going to be selected all right they said
my word is law all right so it'll be very uh awkward if
there was a different plan apparently i was not on the same
wavelength um they're like i think what you want is what we
will do so they assume that we are on the same wavelength so
okay so this is what i thought basically mvp will be
selected by a vote on my channel and then i and guys you
know you could also vote for me because i'm also on
tournament too so but anyway but no no i'm not rigging the
votes guys we're not i'm not i'm just giving a suggestion
wait a bit so it will be the vote for nvp guys it's just
it's just a suggestion i'm not rigging anything um i was
giving an example of how you can vote so it will be a It'll
be a vote on the Twitch channel on the Dokeybird.
Right, got it.
Ricky, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Disclaimer.
I'll give you a little disclaimer.
I was just giving an example.
Just a little, you know, a little example on how it could
work, you know?
It will be like, all right, who you guys want for MVP?
Oh, Dokeybird?
All right, let's put her name on the poll, guys.
And it's like Dokeybird and all the other options.
And if somehow Doki Bird wins, she gets MVP and $2,000.
But you guys can vote for anyone, even for someone who was
on last place too.
You know, you can also vote for someone who was on last
place.
It could also be me there in last place.
But anyway, that is how the MVP system will go.
so you all have a choice on who mvp is not me but you chat
the power is in your hands guys on who you want to vote for
on the dokeybird channel um who your oh she is also uh who
happens to also be dokeybird so it's it's your choice on how
this is gonna go uh
but it could be anyone it could be anyone it could be anyone
um anyway so so day one uh day day day one all right guys
how about okay i think it would be more fair i you know i'm
so humble i'm so humble and like i'm for the people you know
so i my own decision i'm will take myself out of the vote
because I want this tournament to be fair and just and I
know so many people will see me as the most valued player
going in as a person with the most experience going in but
because I am so humble and and I want other people to have a
chance to win MVP everyone a fair opportunity uh hashtag
humble um anyway so day one will be four teams group stage
so it is a round robin um but um the fourth team will get
eliminated before day two uh you're at i agree disgusting um
anyway so so the last place team um the fourth team will get
eliminated on day one and then on day two uh we will go
through the deciding matches between it'll just be like
elimination from uh the last remaining teams um another
thing to add uh about this uh i already forgot what it's
gonna say there's no other thing to add that's it that i
mean the format is pretty straightforward four teams fight
it out the team that loses the most gets eliminated on day
one and oh yeah um we made sure to make the tournament not
too long we didn't combine it on into one day because we
were worried that it might be too long and people will get
tired so uh because of that we split it into determine they
can do whatever they want.
So day two would be a lot shorter compared to day one.
And all matches will be played simultaneously.
So the broadcast will only cover selected matches.
So like there's like a match if you want broadcast this
match.
But every game will be played simultaneously so they don't
have to wait in between games.
You know that's like obviously the worst part.
That's why I hate the most when you got to wait like one to
two hours towards the next game so yeah every game will be
played at once uh to give everyone uh to give every like you
know to move things on like forward in a nice timely manner
um all right next slide whoa captains again all right so
who's gonna be on whose team uh i will start first you will
now understand why i say my team my team is gonna be a
little messy If we manage to work together and not yell at
each other, I will call that a win.
And I created this team, by the way.
I personally created this team, knowing what's going to
happen.
All right.
Anyway, so my team.
All right, Taniy Doki again.
It will be me, Koni, Heavenly Father, Super Gomez, and
Sherpa.
so um it was i was actually the last person to submit my
team because like like i said i had someone drop out last
minute because uh they weren't feeling so good so they're
like i don't think i could do a tournament so it was like
it's okay and then i also was like um so each of us that's
why i'm saying like each of us would be the one to shout res
me Why didn't you rescue each of us?
It could be any one of us.
So it was actually really difficult to create this team
because everyone was apparently like very busy too.
So like I message a lot of people and I'm very thankful to
all the people that said yes to be part of my team and to
participate in this tournament.
So huge shout out to Kony, Heavenly Father, for joining this
tournament and being on my team.
This team, yeah.
I forgot.
Was there team kills?
Was there friendly fire?
I don't remember.
I think there wasn't, right?
Oh, thank God.
There was no friendly fire, guys.
Thank God.
I just remembered.
Wait, there is?
Oh, no.
Wait, never mind.
There was friendly fire.
My mistake.
Oh, okay.
This is gonna, okay.
I don't remember, but then I remembered.
There is friendly.
fire so this is gonna be a little messy let's hope there's
only one way to find out if there's friendly fire or not but
anyway this is my team uh next up uh we have lily pichu and
the bcs so uh yes all of the bcs will be participating i
also want to do another disclaimer we warned her about how
sweaty this this tournament might be oh just a just a little
we're not sending we're not sending a child out to die guys
we warned them also also it is a top-down shooter so like so
like if they see the person first if they see the person
first um they can they they can win the fight I believe.
Okay.
I believe in them.
All right.
I, we all love the underdog story and I believe in them.
So it is Lily Peachy, Berrybug, PFP, Tori, and Tyu.
Um, that will be on Lily Peachy's team.
And I believe in Lily Peachy.
I believe she can lead her team, uh, to victory and not
last.
I believe in her.
Um, but I'm not being last though.
Like if anyone has to be last, I hope I'm sorry Lily if it's
me and you and one of us has to be last I'm sorry but but
but I do not want to be last uh
uh uh uh uh next team will be team Muda so in Muda's team um
it'll be cloudy X3 Camarly NELFPS and dash nerfs uh this is
Muda's team.
But yeah, there they are.
Yay!
I believe they are all very talented in shooters in general.
So, oh my god, there are looks maxing right now.
Yeah, from what I was told, they are gamers.
Gamers.
So, if it's between me and Lily P. you to be not last i am
sorry lily but i will lock in so hard i i do not want to be
like super who got knocked out of his own tournament uh i
have to i have to show up on day two lily i'm sorry i have
to show up on day two i can't give you mercy uh
all right all right last team the very final team will be
team subrosa so it will be a gmdd dynamic simon fps and and
pride i do recognize uh some of the people on this team they
are all also very good at various shooter games and also
like i know like yeah all the teams are pretty stacked i
know like some of them are actually were pros in other games
so uh yeah I know that some of these are gamer gamers who
have been pro players I mean one of them is literally
wearing their jersey shirt so one of them is literally
wearing their their esports sport team so I assume they are
all I mean the other guy has two of them have FPS in their
name so I I assume they're very good at FPS guys put FPS as
your gamer tag you you must be good at FPS because then
because then that would be that would be a little
embarrassing if you it's just there for fun um but yeah
anyway that was Subrosa's team and that was all the teams uh
all the teams for the tournament uh they were invited by the
team captains uh were invited uh by uh PUBG blind spot um
and we allowed the team captains uh to select uh the
teammates that they want to participate in this tournament
so we gave everybody a freedom on who they want to pick and
who they want to join them um so thank you again to the team
captains for participating in uh my creator match uh with
pubg blind spot and also to all the teammates for joining in
as well all right and that's it yay that is um the the the
dokeybird pubg blind spot creator match but we will we're
gonna check out some blind spots but but don't leave yet
don't leave yet guys we're gonna check up blind spot itself
because i actually haven't booted the game yet since the
last time um since the last time i played uh played it uh
which was during the sponsor uh where we were broadcast uh
at a convention so don't leave yet guys we're gonna check up
pubg blind spot and see what else is new who made the local
um it was production team um for a pubg blind spot so they
made all the assets for us and everything so like i said
huge shout out to pubg blind spot if you guys want to
support the um support this tournament support um everyone
here support the game itself uh please feel free to click on
the link pinned in my chat on both twitch and youtube chat
or in the description down on youtube because it does help
out a lot all right let's see let's boop and then big dokey
time all right let me boot up pubg blind spot like i said i
haven't um i haven't touched the game since the last time we
played on stream so um i don't even remember my sense though
to be fair i gotta figure out my sense for this again i
remember we figured out that um we liked it when lacrosse
hair when our movement is based off where we're looking at
so i remember that.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's swap scenes.
But yeah, I hope you guys are excited for the tournament.
As a reminder.
Wait, actually.
I forgot to do this.
Alright.
I love me again.
That's me.
What?
Where is it?
Oh, there we go.
As a reminder, everyone.
The tournament is at February 15th to 16th and that is on
next week on Sunday and Monday 3 p.m.
PSD or 6 p.m.
ESD so yeah be there and support your favorite team or
support me because of course I'm you know I'm your favorite
team right you didn't know you don't let Lily when she's
gonna beat no she's gonna beat up Michael not me
Simple.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But, you know, it could, you know, we could be surprised
because it is a top-down tactical shooter.
And it's usually, I feel like it's Peekers' advantage
because of it.
Because it's like whoever sees the person's first because it
is top-down.
So as long as you put, like, you know, you point your mouse
directly at someone, like, you know, they'll die.
Like, that's...
it works so it could you know anyone can win you know we
don't know who's anyone can win guys all right let me uh oh
you don't hear this music right now all right here we go all
right i gotta make sure you two are visible give me a sec
but out all right here you go yes i know there's two
Timmy's all right let's see you bump bump bump bump bump all
right here we go I accept I gotta accept the stuff real
quick oh jokie bird there's no way somebody already stole my
name yay my name is nobody stole my name thank God I was
gonna say there's no way someone already took my name while
I was introducing the tournament
That'll be pretty awkward.
My Timmy's and Yimmy's will cheer me on.
Alright, let me see.
I'll do.
Flow screen window.
Where is the sensing?
Oh, there it is.
Aligning upwards.
I don't remember.
I don't know if it...
I think it rolls over.
Yeah, this looks like it rolled over.
Okay, and there was like... There was something that I was
just like...
on and off about and it was the where was it it was the one
where it's like wherever you're facing is where you're
shooting at show control show blackout pings I'm not sure if
it's here controls mouse or aim camera line camera rotation
oh there you go choose how to okay there you go align aiming
upwards manual there you go align always align curse okay
there you go I'll do that.
Alright, here we go.
We're going to do the tutorial again.
So wherever I'm facing, so this is where I can turn my
camera.
And then...
Let's...
Walk through slowly.
I'm walking through very slow.
Oh, there you go.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
That's crouch.
Crouching and walking through...
Wait, I changed the tutorial.
This is...
different.
There we go.
Go to the next location.
It is so slow.
What do you mean?
All right, switch to secondary.
There we go.
Go to the next location.
I love ruining.
What do you mean?
All right, fire at target.
Yeah, they changed the tutorial a little bit.
It's different.
Oh, aim low.
Aim low at target area.
Too close to the wall.
What do you mean, too close to the wall?
I'm reloading.
Aim low at target.
Oh, my God.
It's so different now.
Or maybe...
Yeah, it definitely feels different.
I swear to God, I'm aiming low.
What am I doing wrong?
what am i i am pressing control this is control oh my god i
re-binded it that's why wait i remember i re-binded the
controls i give me a sec i forgot what i bided it to it's
not them it's me i re-binded the controls i i remember now
it's like i don't understand i'm because like Control was
not crouched at first.
And then I was like, I don't like that.
I'm going to make it control is crouched.
And I realized, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
That makes more sense now.
What was it?
What did I put it as?
I don't remember.
It's, okay, okay.
Mouse, aim.
Oh, it's C.
Oh my God, it was C.
Why did I put it at sea, Doki?
It's not, it carried over.
It actually carried over.
All the past Doki's control was carried over into this game.
Um, past Doki, why was it sea?
I don't understand.
All right.
So why it did, yeah, I don't, why did I put it at sea?
What the heck was mouse button then?
Alright, guys, I need to rebuy my stuff.
I don't know what Pastor Turkey was thinking.
I don't remember what Pastor Turkey was thinking.
What was my mouse button then?
Okay, melee attack was mouse.
Okay, that was the mouse button.
What about the other mouse button?
Rotate camera?
What was I thinking?
What was that thinking?
Clearly I wasn't.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
Alright, that means...
That means this one.
Aligning...
Okay, here we go.
Confirm.
There we go.
So then that means...
Because I liked it.
Yeah, CC is crouched, but I was like, Oh, I don't like that.
I'm going to change it.
Wow.
What was past Doki thinking?
I'll never find out.
Alright, go to the next location.
Walk to my special gadget.
What is it?
Gash the wall.
I gash the wall?
I did it.
Yeah!
Okay, I'll take you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Last Doki struck again.
Alright.
Swatching my tactic of gadget.
Hatch my nade.
Alright, I got that.
Oh my god.
You can throw your nade so far.
I did not remember that.
Aim great.
Your nade up.
Okay.
Oh yeah, I remember that now.
There we go.
all right go to the next location watch this grenade out oh
okay it's okay just a little friendly fire i'm just
practicing just practicing friendly fire for my team hit
down all right i don't know about uh wait can i hit from can
i wallbang glass no oh wait that's the grenade right Yeah,
look at that.
I think, yeah, I remember, like, in the end, I liked facing
towards where I'm planning on shooting.
I felt like that was, like, the most convenient overall.
All right, one more to go.
Where's the last one?
Oh, right in front of me.
Yay!
There's gonna be...
I gotta let them know.
I'll be like, there is friendly fire, guys.
There is friendly fire.
Guys, all right.
I want to buy agents.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, give me a sec.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm going to do something pretty magical.
Watch this.
Give me a sec.
Do I do this?
Oh, wait, I already did it.
Okay, wait.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna do something really magical.
You're gonna be, like, so impressed.
Watch this.
It's like, uh, it's like a, it's like the, it's like that
code, you know?
You put a code down, and then suddenly you have, and
suddenly something magical is happening.
Uh, give me a sec.
It's gonna have, oh, wait, what?
What is, what do you mean?
There we go.
Look at this.
and now oh wait you guys can't see sorry uh yimmy's covering
it up but but look at that i did a special input i did like
up up down down left right right down left and then oh my
god i'm rich now i'm how does she do it see i know the
secret is the special input the special input where after
you put it in you get 12 000 uh dude okay so oh i can buy
all of them okay i'm gonna buy patch i don't remember what
all of them did i remember haze was pretty broken and then i
could buy two more and then i guess fuck the other guy uh oh
i should buy blaze because he's new also i realized blaze
reminds me of axel wait he reminds me of axel and it was so
funny because he like messaged When I announced my
tournament, he messaged me because he thought it was the
original PUBG Battlegrounds game because he's been craving
PUBG Battlegrounds and he was wanting to, like, an actual
custom in NA.
And then he was like, oh my God, are you full?
Can I still, can I still enjoy it?
And I was like, Axel, I'm sorry, Axel, it's a different
game.
I was like, it's a different game.
It ain't Battle Royale, Axel.
It's a top-down tactical shooter.
And he's like, oh, I'm going to tot, tot, tot.
I was like, do you still want to do it?
And he was like, no.
Because he wanted to play PUBG Battleground.
He was just craving for PUBG Battleground.
All right.
We get Buddy or Zed.
Alright, actually, he has Sticky Launcher, Drill Camera.
Oh, I'm not, I don't know how to do Intel.
I'll just buy, I'll just buy Zen.
I don't know, I'm sorry, buddy.
I'm bad at Recon.
I don't remember which one I liked the most.
You guys remember which one I played?
A lot of?
There was one character I was, like, spamming.
I think it was Panatic, right?
Because she had a Metcalfe.
Was it Panatic or who was it?
Go back to Batty.
mean buddy.
Do you guys remember which one I played?
Uh, the last time I played this game?
It's like, I'm trying to remember because I liked a specific
gun.
It was a specific gun that I really liked.
No, it was like, it was an aim gun.
And the shield.
I remember I played him.
I remember I played him during defense.
He was...
No, it was the guy with the hammer!
I was Breachman!
I don't...
No, guys!
Did you forget the of hammer i was the breach man oh wait
actually yeah i said all how could i forget about you
actually we'll do team death match first i was the breach
man only one guy can breach and that would be me all right
let's do this is team death match i want to try i want to
try out the different uh we'll do we'll try it we'll test it
out all right i believe in us team we just gotta shoot oh
never mind all right just gotta shoot each other oh where is
he where is he oh shit wait oh my god he shot his teammate
oh my god that was so fast oh Oh my god, I gotta remember
there is friendly fire.
Oh my god, where are they?
Where are they?
I'm so paranoid.
Guys, where is my shared vision?
Oh, they are cooking us right now.
Oh my, oh my god, stupid shared vision!
Why don't you give me the shared vision?
No, there is absolutely friendly fire.
Holy shit!
I'm a dude!
I'm sorry, team!
my first game.
Wait, shared vision.
There we go.
See?
It's possible.
Anybody can win.
It's Peekers' advantage.
Oh my god.
Yeah, see?
There you go.
Shared vision.
Found.
Oh my guys.
Guys.
Come on, guys.
Okay, I am a little messed up right now, though.
I really need heals.
Watch this.
Reloading.
Cover me.
Boom!
Oh, shit!
Double kill?
All me, guys.
All me.
All right, I'm going to go back to base, home base, to grab
HP.
There you go.
Double HP?
Oh, I don't have shields.
Look at that.
Double kill.
See?
I used my brain.
Okay, to 30.
All right, there you go.
That's all right.
awkward.
Don't worry.
Boom.
That'll work again, surely.
I told you that'll work again.
I told you.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I know he's right there, too.
What?
Oh, my God.
That shotgun was so far.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I'm doing my part, though.
I did.
I'm doing my part in this team.
Where everyone's
there we go i got you i got you and then my team shot me
bro everyone's just like like a little baby there you go
surely somebody will walk over there oh my god kills
remaining okay
he's so bad
I figured it out.
Guys, I told you I could figure this out.
Oh my god.
He's one.
Come on, guys.
We just need one kill.
I cannot do everything.
Yay.
I did it.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I'm pretty sure.
Most skills, most damage dealt.
10 by 10, by 10, by the way.
By, look, it took me a while to get started.
It took me a while to get started.
But like, after I figured it out, guys, after I figured it
out, I locked in.
I locked in.
We have someone with 7% accuracy.
At least they're not on my team.
They're not on my team.
it's okay see we did it all right now let's actually be
tactical all right now we go into the big boy leagues the
big boy big boy leagues now
all right what step noise can be greatly reduced by walking
Everybody's walking.
Oh my god, it's gonna mess me up.
Where's the... Where's Breachman?
No!
Breachman!
I don't know what else to play now!
That was the only guy I knew how to play.
Um...
Oh, no.
Oh, okay.
Alright, I'm a cat girl now.
The plan My entire plan relied on playing one person And now
it's over There you go here Whoa That was my entire plan
Alright how do I play this person Hand foam grenade And um
Guys what is my util
This was my entire plan.
Oh, my God.
That shotgun is...
Have a hammer, guys.
Alright.
What the?
What is he doing over there?
Shoot him!
Bro, shoot him!
Why didn't you shoot him?
I was gonna shoot you.
I didn't want a friendly fire.
what was what was the plan oh oh my god i was about to throw
this i was about to he's fine don't worry i got you buddy
wait did we double tap did we double tap oh my god oh my god
i don't even get to get res
what do you mean i did a good thing I did a good thing And I
get punished for it I swear Okay that was a good wallbang I
had no rest for you I did a guys guys The 8 guys you have
Dot God you have bomb What are you I can't believe it It's
alright my team did it Yeah It was okay.
My team did it.
Yay!
Alright.
We did it, guys.
We're so good.
I'm gonna be so useful now.
Alright.
We're attack again.
Okay, I need to figure it.
Remote charge.
What?
Alright.
What does he do?
Guys, like, they took the one character I knew how to play.
Like, what am I...
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
I'm gonna throw the motion sensor right here.
So we get flanked.
If we get flanked, then I'll know.
Alright, where are we going?
I follow Lou.
Also, why the heck was he over there?
Home your blind spot so you don't get maxed out.
I'm so scared.
I'm so paranoid of friendly fire now, guys.
I'm so paranoid.
I feel like I'm going to actually shoot my team.
See?
Alright, here we go.
Did he just flash himself?
You wanted a challenge, guys.
You don't understand.
Here we go.
You have the hammer.
Jesus.
Alright, there's no one there this time.
Oh my god.
I mean, I could still shoot it.
Like, it's not like...
I could still shoot this.
Like, it's not like, you know...
Wait, he's dead, right?
The colors are gone.
Back up a bit.
Alright, don't worry.
They'll never know.
Don't worry.
Motion sensor!
They'll never see...
Oh, my God, they saw.
Grenade out.
though.
I lost my sensor.
Don't worry.
Don't never.
I got the second sensor.
Oh, there you go.
See?
They never expect a second sensor.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I'm scared.
Wait, I have bomb.
My bad.
Wait, no, everyone has bomb, right?
What's that thing?
Are I planting?
Cover me, cover me, cover me, cover me Right there, yep,
there we go Planted
Motion sensor, placed They were No One enemy left They were
no
Yeah!
I didn't have to do anything Let's go!
Yo!
Yay!
Wait, that motion sensor goes hard though.
Wait, I figured it out.
No, no, no.
I was the backup flag.
I couldn't shoot because he was in front of me.
What if I shot my team, guys?
Like, guys, I could have shot my team.
I was trying to not shoot him.
Because there's friendly fire.
I got scared.
If he dies.
Yeah, see, I practice restraint, chat.
I practice restraint in not accidentally killing my team.
And that's all that matters.
I have to be able to restrain myself before the tournament.
All right, this is a new attack now.
Camera's live.
All right, you got this, Lou.
Camera that.
Damn, okay.
Motion sensor, wait.
Oh, shit.
Enemy spotted.
It's crazy for that.
Reloading, cover me.
Oh, wait, shoot that guy.
Shoot him.
Okay, I was gonna say, I don't really want to shoot that
guy.
Oh Oh Reloading cover me I swear I saw Wait, there's a guy
right?
Oh shit Breaching the wall Wait There we go There we go,
there was another guy right here There we go That's right
One bang Oh I know you're Oh shit one more i'm coming over
that's right never expected me on the other side okay we're
this is the most tactical i've ever been all right now it's
defense okay who was the best for defense it was like oh
this this one i remember i used her because i had medkit i
can just heal myself i'm so tactical look at that Look at
that.
These guys are super new.
That's me.
Alright, don't worry, guys.
I shall...
What is it?
Alright, deploy a barricade.
And then...
You'll never expect this.
Or this.
That's right.
And then...
Barricade!
Alright.
Even...
Alright, I don't know why we breached that.
Okay, it's fine.
And then what if I barricade this wall, too?
And then...
And then I'm gonna put a...
I'm scared.
I'm gonna put Medkit right here.
Medkit's here.
In the open.
this is bait don't worry the med kid is bait the med kid is
just bait oh my god where the fuck do I stand where I won't
get shot there you go this is where do I position where I
don't get shot I am very scared I'm so safe here surely
right oh my god I forgot about this area too many angles.
Why did we fucking destroy that wall?
Where do I even look?
Where do I where do I look?
Why did we destroy that wall?
Okay.
One minute remaining.
That's five.
Nobody's gonna come over here.
We're so safe.
one enemy left oh nice oh wait it's one enemy left i can
just roam it's roaming time
we just robed where could the last guy be though oh 30
seconds remaining where is he oh shit what could he be just
oh my god that guy's just destroying everything hello He
went outside.
Firing gap.
10 seconds remaining.
Wait, did he like, did he hit?
Oh my god, he was back over there.
We did it guys!
We won!
Yay!
Look at that, I'm ready for the tournament.
I'm so ready.
We're so ready for the tournament, guys.
It's that easy, see?
Alright, one more.
more.
But yeah, if you guys want to check out the game right now,
you can, it's literally free to play, and it's an early
access at the moment.
So you can actually try the game right now, and you can
download the game by clicking the link on my chat, pinned in
my chat, use the command, or in the description under
YouTube, under my YouTube stream.
Yeah, and you can play it right now.
Match found.
Alright, here we go.
again all
right what do i i like the motion sensor girl only because
like i'm so paranoid
i'm so goddamn paranoid i feel like the motion sensor helps
with that all right wait unless someone is anybody playing
lu wait wait i get to be hammer boy no one's hammer boy oh
my god free hammer boy
all right here we go it's a really paranoid of they're
actually out to get you no don't say that
it's time it's time to it's hammer time it's like oh my god
did you see that crazy tweet from the creators of digital
circus and she was like and people were like We're like, why
did you...
They're like, you are actually being watched.
That's right.
Your favorite character is out to...
I'm like, oh my god!
Why would you tweet that?
Yeah.
Did you actually tweet?
I was like, you are actually being watched.
I was like, oh my god.
That's crazy.
That's actually a crazy thing to say.
What?
I didn't even have a chance!
Oh my god.
I looked out at the window one time.
I don't even get to crawl.
I don't even get the privilege to crawl.
I just wanted to hammer.
I wanted to hammer.
Oh, that guy's crazy.
Oh my god, the Jiggle Peaks, though.
It's okay, my team can carry me.
I believe in my team.
She's planning.
Look at them go.
Well, how do I expect the next person?
Wait, that is so smart.
Write this down.
Guys, write this down for my tournament.
Wait, that is so smart.
Why is this face?
The pawn plant is next to the window.
Guys, write this down.
I will choose this map so I can plant right here.
Okay.
I will plan it right here.
Guys, write this down so I won't be last place.
The coolest not last.
Oh my god, my team is smart.
The enemy can do...
Yeah, but if we do it first, it'll be different.
Guys, I don't think Hammer Boy is good in this map.
Maybe.
Yeah, no...
sell platen your windows i have a feeling that maybe maybe
hammer boy might not be great for this particular area oh
that guy's level eight already i might need more than a
habit
all right see you guys but i'm figuring it out slowly but
sure i'm relearning the game for next week slowly but surely
it will work out eventually
risk I'm willing to take.
Alright, I'm going to believe in my team to show me the way.
Reloading, cover me.
I have motion.
Oh, wait.
Is that same bad spot?
No.
Oh my god, it is.
There you go.
There's no way.
Oh my god, they're fracking out.
That's crazy.
I literally looked up one second.
Oh
my god, he's right there.
I'm scared, guys.
He's like, come on, you got this.
I have to be
the smartest shit I ever done.
What the fuck?
He crouched!
He fucking crouched!
So I'm going to shoot at him!
Oh!
He crouched!
Oh my god!
I'm done so!
We can do that!
You can just crouch!
Okay, now I know.
Guys, now I know in the tournament.
In the tournament, I should just crouch.
I was like, I got him.
And then he started crouching.
crouching.
The crouch technique.
It like clicked in my head.
I was like, bro, mad mad's crouching.
I can't even shoot him in the head.
His entire body was fucking crouched.
Just, okay, now I know.
I'll just keep crouching.
Bro!
That's why you gotta shoot the toes!
You gotta shoot the got that toes just crouch he knew how to
drop shot like it's 2007.
all right guys note this down note this out we have to we
have to we have to crouch when we're shooting we gotta shoot
the toes now we know we shoot the toes you'll
never expect plat b a third time i think they're all going
wait what where are they going
what i okay that hurts me
okay guys i don't know the util for that so blue hurts me
apparently who would have thought it's okay my team's
picking it up up for me i don't know what the fuck i'm doing
but my team is doing it
where's my plant the bomb oh shit oh okay what is he what is
he doing what is did he dc
did he did he see what the fuck was this plant the same
thing so let's just get a lot of like
And then if they do, we just save our...
No, I think our third guy actually DC'd.
Yeah, he's gone!
I was like, oh no!
No, he's gone, God!
Oh no!
Wait, wait, this is loosable now!
This is loosable!
What?
Alright.
Don't worry, yes.
What if there's a third razor wire?
Medkits here.
Don't worry, there's no way they wall banged this.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
oh my god no after one minute no my monitor is gonna turn
off after one minute has to do a little maintenance oh no i
have to live in one minute oh no this is so bad after one
minute oh nice oh not nice wait he killed his friend one
minute dream no i won't be able to see the monitor boom
incoming One minute remaining.
Moment coming.
Oh, no.
The decryptor has been planted.
Oh, my God.
That actually hurts me.
Enemy's here.
Watch out.
Oh, no.
I'm going to go the other side.
See?
No!
My mind is shut down.
It had to do a bit.
Oh, no.
Okay, we can fix this.
I'll play on my second monitor.
We can We can figure this out.
Okay.
All right.
I'm looking on my via my OBS.
My OBS.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I can't swap it to my second monitor.
I can't be like, oh, no.
I actually to play on my ob okay all right we can do this
okay setting wire okay there it's fine guys i don't know you
guys can tell but i'm playing via my obs right now my ob is
creep
oh my god this is so bad this is so bad
This is so bad.
It's doing a maintenance right now.
Oh,
no.
Oh, no, this is so bad for me.
Oh, my God.
It truly is a blind spot.
I'm actually, I'm like trying, I'm full screenplay on my
OBS, trying to make this work, guys.
I really am.
My monitor had to go into maintenance mode at the last
second.
I'm sorry.
It's so tiny.
Everything is so tiny on the screen.
It's okay.
We can make this work.
If we lose this because I don't even have my monitor on.
I legitimately have the perfect excuse chat.
I don't.
My monitor is off.
Guys, I have actually the perfect excuse.
Monitor, please come back.
Because I don't think the monitor is coming back.
I don't think so.
I'm gonna lock my oh wait actually Razor wires down
Oh my god I don't feel so good
Throw in the gadget I'm so scared I hear so many people I
feel like I'm heading back
Oh my god It's okay.
I'm just down.
I am so reasonable Don't worry.
I'll give you it.
There you go I'll give you I'll give you a little I'll go
Guys guys I'm look I should have thrown sensors, but also
guys I am playing oh my god my main mod and just oh my god
my What is he doing?
Oh no my mod and just turned on
That's the worst.
My monitor actually just turned on.
No!
Okay, okay, I can be useful now.
I can be sort of useful now.
I...
Good thing.
Okay, my monitor came back on, guys.
We can salvage this.
We can...
salvage this all right here you go now i can lose with
vision exactly exactly now all right
this is come come back time i can now i can lose with vision
i've never had that happen before where i've never had had
to happen before with my fucking monitor like does a
maintenance mode mid to stream but goddamn wild oh nice that
was convenient wait I got you guys wait they destroyed oh my
god I did it guys I helped she was wild oh my god see one
enemy left motion detector place watch behind us there
was guys see see my monitor was on my the
deciding factor all right I contributed I got monitoring
this it was all fire at the plant they're like god we have
this stupid dokey bird on our team she's not doing nothing
and then i was like yeah because i was playing with my
monitor off like i was like i wanted to make this game fair
you know for the other team so i had to play with it off i
oh but you want i guess because you guys want to win i guess
i'll turn my monitor on now i almost throwing but winning it
makes for Got it.
Look at that.
Jeez, jeez.
I carried the shit out of that last game.
Like, so good.
I just have to turn them on, you know what?
All right.
Thank you again.
Like I said, thank you again to...
But Twitch.
Timmy's.
Don't go yet.
Don't go yet, Timmy's.
Because I'll be staying a little bit longer on Twitch.
but yimmies actually i don't know if i can do that can i do
that wait i can't all right uh to the yimmies thank you all
for coming uh to the stream um yes because i'm gonna i'm
gonna do another game i'm gonna play something else so like
you know be weird on the on the youtube vibe uh we're gonna
be swapping to another game um but i want to say thank you
again to PUBG Blindspot for sponsoring today's stream and
the tournament.
And the announcement, please check out the tournament next
week on February 15th, 2016.
Let me pull it up real quick.
Wow!
Oh, hey, that's me.
That's me right there.
All right.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Also, I hope the volume was okay.
I did not check.
I did not sound check at all.
I hope.
hope the volume wasn't too loud yes i was not but a little
reminder for everybody but the tournament will be on
february 15th to 16th at 3 p.m pst so make sure to be there
to support your team and me for this tournament i'll see you
guys next week everyone um but yeah i will still be
streaming on twitch but thank you again uh if you guys want
to support me the stream the game the tournament Please
click the link pinned in both chats, both YouTube and Twitch
chat, or in the description below.
It really does help out the channel, the streams, and the
sponsor a lot.
And by the way, you can play PUBG Blindspot right now for
free.
It is free to play, so you can check out the game yourself.
All right, guys, to the YouTuber YouTube chat.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause, check, get up,
and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
Stay up for me.
Head to bed, because you deserve it.
still be here but we're gonna say goodbye right now to
youtube goodbye youtube i actually never tested this out so
we'll see if i can stop youtube and keep on going on twitch
so we can i'll say goodbye to both of you guys so we're
gonna check try this out for the first time